Hey, what's going on? It's bill burn. It's
the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
April 20th,
April 20th.
I you doing what's going on?
Talking to you from the road.
Don't you know, I'm sorry. I'm
in the middle of nowhere, man.
I'm in fucking Chattanooga,
Tennessee and I haven't seen shit.
I haven't seen shit here yet.
I ain't seen shit air yet. Um,
I'm in the middle of the southern
tour here. Uh, traveling on the bus,
fueling up next to truckers. It's a whole
other world, man. Whole other worlds,
those truck drivers, you
know, but you know what?
I only saw one real fat one
or sell one fatty, you know,
one big guy was just
like, dude, you need to,
you need to start jogging some
laps around your truck, man,
that's gotta be the hardest fucking
job to stay in shape. Holy Shit.
Yeah.
So one guy has fucking sitting there.
He's got a dog in there, you know,
how the fuck do you make any time
when you've got a dog? I mean,
do you get to fucking pull
over every couple hours, right?
I guess you got to get gas anyways.
I think they had to take a shit.
You know,
it's like you just fucking pull it over.
It's a goddamn 18 wheeler oh 18.
Um, anyways, this is the
Monday morning podcast.
This is going to be a fucked up one cause
I'm an a silly ass mood and I have no
idea what's going on
in the world right now.
I know that there was some refugees
that floated over on some little boat,
not a little boat lake, 700 people.
Uh, God, I fucking hate those stories.
They always skip the part to where they
go. There's some bodies being seen.
They didn't never talk about all that.
Quint from Jaws Shit,
the amount that we're treading water and
got eaten by sharks. Dude, you know bad.
A country has to be for you to fucking
okay.
Take your chances doing that.
This or you wouldn't get me
up front of fucking lake. I,
I don't,
I do not fuck with I go into poles.
I will in a pool all goddamn day.
Fuck that. I wouldn't go on a pond.
Fuck that.
Goddamn people trying to
cross the Mediterranean Sea.
I don't even know where they were
coming from. Jesus Christ. Now,
how do you it as a dictator, dead point
d d how do you not know at that point?
Like, Hey, maybe I, uh, maybe I should
ease up a little bit on the people here.
They're fucking,
they're trying to cross the
Mediterranean on a Goddamn Hooptie
will fucking boogie boards and shit. At
that point, you got to know, you know,
it even if you didn't give a shit about
them, you'd have to be thinking like, um,
I think there's going to be an attempt
made on my life pretty soon. You know,
considering 700 people just died.
You figured they got to have a bunch of
people that loved him, right? It's eight,
three people loved all those people.
There's 2100 people that want to fucking
kill me extra today as a dictator.
Um, you know, probably help affect,
she looked to see which one it was the
only dictator I knew when that got beaten
to death by shit from auto zone.
Remember that Guy Kadafi he got beaten
to death with like fucking car batteries
and antennas walking around with half
his fucking uniform on and I was a
travesty,
you know what I mean?
That was like worse than seeing Emmitt
Smith playing for the Arizona cardinals
and all that.
You know,
like when you just see like a
me versus you talk about that.
Patrick knew Patrick Ewing when
he played for like Orlando.
Just seeing him in that uniform,
seeing Kadafi walking around with half
his boy scout uniform on begging for his
life. Like I was a fan.
But you know, it's like,
Gee, you got an, you know,
you gotta know when to get
out of show business and that,
that includes being a dictator. You
gotta know, you gotta be able to feel it.
You gotta be sitting there going,
all right,
people are leaving this country w and
shit boats just to get away from me.
How much longer are they going
to put up? Put up with me? How,
how much longer can I,
can I keep the facade going that I can
beat everybody's ass one on one here in
this country? You know
what I mean? I Dunno man.
Hang on a sec.
Let me find it.
Can we at least have the decency for
the victims to know where that went,
where it went? You know, that's terrible.
That's terrible that
that happened to them.
But I gotta tell you it's good for
the baby seals. You know what I mean?
Cause that's 700 less people eating
fish now and they actually fed fish.
What they did was tremendous. You
know, if you guys seen that story,
it's like there's like baby
seals washing up on the ocean.
I'm going on the ocean washing up on
the beach just cause they're starving to
death because the oceans
are so fished out.
This is probably a bad thing to bring up.
You know,
when he's sitting there
reading this thing, alright,
London rescue grabbed scrambled.
Why? I want this stock fucking thing.
Let me select it. There we go.
All right, where did this happen?
It's being reported from
London Mediterranean, uh,
crossing Europe to
Europe from Africa. Okay.
All right.
Okay.
More than 17 vessels. We're searching
for the survivors. Uh, my God,
70 miles off the coast of Libya now,
Olivia,
and as in that where Kadafi used to
fucking cut all his hits and he used to
record out there.
Okay.
All the, you know, the fucking
teen idols sensation out there.
I gotta look this up here. Libya. Libby,
a dictator. D a Tor
dictator. Who Do you got?
Who Do you got on more?
Sadat. Momar. Kadafi.
Okay.
And I fucked. Do you take shit from
a guy named Momar? You have to do it.
Moma. I said no, fuck him. He never
looked like he was a bad ass daddy.
He just always looked like a,
he just thought that was just bad casting.
I'm going to go dominant.
Votech guy.
Worst like most unintimidating
like fucking dictator ever.
He just look at his face. I don't know
what he looks. He just looks like a,
you know, he looked like to
me was a, what's his face?
Oh Christ. What's his name? Bobby. Uh, AH,
fuck. I'm the worst. I
got to get off the road.
The fuck is his name.
Oh Jesus.
It's the perfect fucking analogy too.
It's going to tour it. I'll remember it.
I'll remember it by the end of this.
Um,
anyways, I'm just saying the guy's
face. He looks, you know what it is.
He looks like this guy that I know
that I can't remember his fucking name.
This is going off the rails over
here. Um, all right. Anyway,
so we're on the, we're on the
southern tour here. We did a,
we did Savannah the first night and uh,
just a great crowd,
beautiful city and um, you
know the usual shit. We go up,
me and me in a fucking lie ahead.
We flew out on the 17th,
because we're coming from the west
coast and we show up. You know,
we don't have a Wii. We don't have a
vehicle with staying out by the airport.
So we're nowhere near downtown Savannah.
I didn't see anything in Savannah.
I didn't see old town. I didn't see
shit. I always wanted to go there.
I never even got to it cause we was
staying way out by the airport and the bus
hadn't shown up yet. Right. So we say to
the lady downstairs, right? First of all,
they fucking check and she takes
my driver's license. And as always,
just starts typing shit in. I
go, what are you doing? She goes,
I'm typing in your home address.
And it's just like, for what? Well,
just in case you leave something,
while if I leave something of value,
I'll call you guys. I'll notice. And then
I'll call you guys. And then you guys,
of course, we'll say you couldn't find
it because it was of a v. It was a value.
The housekeeper that you're not
paying shit is going to keep it.
There's no reason for you to
fucking take my home address.
You just going to sell it to somebody
else to make a little bit of money.
So today I went to go check in the
hotel and she takes my fucking driver's
license. She goes, type in. I
said, what are you doing? She goes,
I'm typing in your home address. And I
go, uh, I don't want you to do to do that.
She goes, you don't want me to do that?
I said, yes, I don't want you to do that.
She goes, okay, how about just
a zip code? And I said No.
And she said, okay. So that's what I
learned today. It's fucking optional.
Fucking assholes.
This fucking take your Id.
Just telling these people to just start
fucking typing your God damn address in
there. What the fuck he
get doing? Renting a room.
Here's my credit card.
Here's my id saying that's my credit
card now fuck off and give me a room.
You got to know where I lived.
Huh?
You fucking Weirdos telling you
people don't do that. Don't do that.
Cause they uploaded onto their
shit and then, and then it's just,
it's just out there.
And next thing you know,
I don't know what if you're lucky,
you just getting spammed by a red roof
inn getting shit sent to you directly.
You're really unlucky.
I don't know what happens.
Some of these fucking steal your identity.
Somebody shows up at your fucking,
I mean,
either way it's rude and it's
completely fucking unnecessary and a,
and I'll tell you right now, I'll
tell you right now, this, this,
this freckled face cunt
is a, is against it. 100%.
100%. Um, so anyways,
so we say to the lady downstairs at the,
uh,
at the hotel where like, so,
uh, you know, we walk in, right?
I see la had,
had sees me,
we obviously know we're going to start
drinking immediately. And I ask, you know,
we walk in his hotel bar still open. She's
like, no, now it isn't a jazz closed.
I'm sorry. You want me to go
make you some? You're down south.
We're really polite. And I was
like, no, that's all right.
You don't have to make it some is
there a bar nearby? And she goes, yeah,
there's one on her and her hair
straight. And I'm like, all right,
can you walk there from there?
She's a, Oh no, Nah, y'all, y'all.
Y'All can't walk here from, Hey, you
can't walk or it's too far again,
why you all get attacked
by a wild cat or something?
And I was just like, all right, well
let me look this fucking thing up.
And I looked it up. It was like, it
was like a fucking barely a mile away.
Yeah. It's like, what do you
eat? Meat, you can fucking walk.
So we fucking walk over there.
We literally walk half the half a mile
of the walk was getting out of the
Goddamn fucking hotel area and
then we just took down the streets.
We see lights, we see civilization.
Ah, you can't walk down.
I mean you could do it, but I mean, I
don't know what, what happened to you?
So we go all the way down.
She didn't even talk like that.
I just like the southern accent and
fucking annoying people from where I'm
touring.
So we fucking head all the way down there.
We ended up walking to this bar.
Is this a little band in there?
Guy On guitar and a guy playing
drums that both killing it,
singing all this shit from the 90s.
Fucking tremendous.
We'll fucking drinking right now.
You get shocked was they'd go given the
shots at Jamison and glasses that they
had just taken out of the dishwasher.
So the glass was off.
Those was between warm
and kind of hot was gross.
It was making me sick to my
stomach, but I can't drink. Um,
and I don't know what happened.
We just sat there laughing our asses off.
We were watching some
sort of, some, some game.
I don't even know what the fuck we
were watching. And next thing you know,
I really,
I looked up and we were the only two
people left in the place and we were too
drunk to fucking walk back.
We didn't want to. So, uh,
this,
the dude at the bar,
this gay dude who was wearing a kilt
for whatever fucking reason, I think,
cause it was an Irish bar,
he gave us a ride home.
So that's how it started.
It was a great guy.
He came walking over and he
just took off fucking beers,
put them in paper cups and
he does let us drink it.
That last little mile on the way home.
And then I walked in to the hotel and
I said to the lady, you know, hey it,
can you still order room service?
Is there any way we can order
some servers up to the room, some,
some service room service
stuff. He's like, ah Nah, Nah,
I can't just clouds clouds.
I'm salary.
I'll you want me mama go hostile and go
kill a fathom. Fari I'll cook it out.
I'll brand it how deep frack manky
some dumplings. And we like, Nah, Nah,
that's cool.
That's cool.
And I went over and I bought a bag of
fucking potato chips and went upstairs and
laid in bed drunk in,
ate a bag of chips and fell asleep.
That's how the tour started.
Remember I told you guys I was going
to try to not put on any weight.
That's how it started.
That's what set the fucking tone right.
Then the next day the Goddam bus pulls up,
right?
The bus pulls up and we see that
thing and it's just, I don't know.
We've been actually been doing pretty
good though as far as, um, you know,
I went out and I got a, I got
some cereal, I've got corn checks,
right? I get some bananas. So that's my
breakfast. And then I got some Turkey,
did all of this in Walmart.
So God knows what level of quality
this shit actually is. Oh my God, dude,
you go into a Walmart.
Holy Shit.
You cannot believe the loss of hope
and those fucking people's eyes.
This fucking lady, this fucking
lady, when I went up to the Deli,
I mean, I was just like, hey, how you
doing? I'm fucking turning on the charm.
I have what's going on? How I, and she
just fucking looking at me. She's like,
what do you want? Just like, uh,
can I get a, uh, pounded that
smoked Turkey police? She's Zadie.
It as like a, you know, didn't come
in. You real hi. Hey, how you doing?
And some of you just fucking hits you
with your attitude and you immediately got
to adjust all the way down to them.
You know,
it's like the way I lost
out on the negotiations last
week on the rug, you know?
And um, so I go from, hey, how's it going?
[inaudible] uh, yeah, we'll have some, uh,
helps them Turkey. She's
like that it, that it,
that's what she said that
it, and I was like, uh,
yeah,
I can't get like, you know, 15 slices
of cheese, you know, white Cheddar,
white American. Whenever
he got, she's like, Yep,
she fucking goes over and just cuts it up.
And like,
I can't even tell you the way
she like handed it to me. Well,
just sort of looking off into
the distance down the isles,
you know, and uh, it was just,
you know, so now, you know,
I'm shaking it off,
right.
I'm getting some fucking
condiments for the sandwiches,
pickles that got my mustard and I get it.
I get down to the booze,
I realized I don't have any hard stuff.
So I throw in a six, a fucking blue moon,
whatever.
That's the best they got here and this
fucking assholes have the nerve on a
Sunday to not let me buy a six pack of
beer. The lady took it away from me.
I had it on a little conveyor
belt and she's fucking, you know,
boop boop corn checks boob,
right? Half Gallon of 2% milk.
Everything's going fine and then she goes,
she goes,
I can't let you have this and took it
away from me and set it on the other side
of the register. Like I was going
to lunge after it or something.
I can't let you have this.
It's before 1230 on a
Sunday and I was just,
I a second. We fucking adults
here. You already, I'll do
the way they fucking treat
their employees there. How bad,
how poorly Walmart treats
their fucking employees.
They're going to have the nerve to
not let people drink before noon.
They should be letting those people drink
on the job. I was fucking miserable.
They treat those damn people.
How do I know they treat them miserably?
I don't know.
I just heard they have,
they won't give me my beer. So now I'm
trashing up. That's what I'm doing.
I'll tell you, they got some
fucking clothes in there though.
They got some decent clothes.
You know,
if you just adjust your
ego down a little bit,
they got some decent clothes and Walmart,
like you could make it work.
You don't feel it gives you,
maybe if he just fucking spend a little
more money on your pants, then I know.
You know what? You got it.
This is what you gotta do.
If you're going to fucking
go cheap on something,
you can't do anything near eye level.
You can't,
you can't get away with a cheap shirt.
You know what I mean?
You just got to buy in real nice shirt.
Then the rest of it can look like shit,
but you have to be charismatic to keep
people looking you in the eye because the
second you start losing their intention,
you're their attention, you know?
And they started looking down
at the guy like guy, Guy,
what am I looking at this motherfuck
why am I talking to him? Right.
They're going to see your shoes
and it's going to be over.
I think it'd be like this
motherfucker shops at Walmart.
He goes down to Wally
world. Shit, we all do.
We all go down there to buy fucking
an eight pound box of fucking weedies.
We all do that shit.
But this guy actually goes down there
and buy the shirts and I know what you're
saying right now bill,
why are you making fun of people who
can't afford to shop any place else other
than Walmart?
And there's a simple answer to that.
They're not in the room with me right now.
Okay.
They can't do me any harm and I am
unbelievably tough on my podcast.
A fucking trash. Anybody. Um,
okay.
My dream is,
is that people who wear Walmart clothes
climb over the walls of gated community
someday and they just start murdering
bankers and heads of corporations.
Okay.
And then in the fight everybody dies.
So then you weed out your
mouth breathing racist. Okay.
And their spawn.
And then you get rid of the guys up top
and then once you got in the middle is a
bunch of regular fucking people
don't want to get fucked with.
They're willing to get up,
go down the street, you know,
sell some apples, come home. Right.
That's what I do in my dream world.
I have no idea what I'm talking about.
How much bullshit that I just
throw it. Yes, that was good.
18 minutes of your life,
you're never getting that back.
How do you feel you're getting through
the traffic? When he listening to this?
I'm open. I'm open. The volumes fine.
And in the last couple of weeks,
every once in a while the volume gets bad.
It sounds fine to me.
Did I just spell Libya? L Y.
Bia? I think I did lie BF.
Who's that guy from Labia? I don't know
who he is. He ain't from here. Oddly.
We should mom. But you're in a
fair on, on my own. Battle Nail,
nail nail. Um, all right. Let's get this
a little bit of advertising for this week.
Oh, by the way, I got to talk
to you guys about Blake Griffin.
I like Blake Griffin.
I enjoy watching the guy play basketball,
but it is impossible for me to do that
when I'm sitting next to fucking Paul
Versey or Jason Law had
they fucking trashed thing.
No matter what the guy does it matter what
he does. He fucking dunks on somebody.
Yeah, the guy got there
late. That was more the past.
I did it on some second string guy.
Chris Paul does something.
They're fucking jerking off.
I'm not saying Blake Griffin's as
good as is Chris Paul, but I mean,
you know the man is wildly entertaining.
He is electrifying.
He fucking has dunked on everybody in
the Goddamn League. Get off his back.
They're acting like he's Joe Barry Carroll
out there like they wasted a bunch of
fucking money. That guy, he, he's
helping to put the clippers on the map.
You could fucking walk up to a
clippers game before that guy came out.
He didn't give a shit about that.
Dairy is miles guy doing
the fucking antenna thing.
That's the closest they ever came to.
Anybody given a fuck about them. Right.
Billy Crystal deserves a god Damn Sports
Medal of honor for the amount of games
that he has sat through.
That guy said,
fuck the Lakers and
everybody else who goes down.
I'm going with the clippers guys go and
he's contrary. You know, by the way,
did I mention,
I did you guys,
we have you guys been watching
the comedian jet fucking
great show and the pilot
episode,
that pilot episode where they're trying
to get that show off the ground the way
they did that. That's pretty much
almost exactly just the, the,
the conversations putting two guys
together that don't want to be together,
but they were, they were,
their careers are at,
they kind of have to be a half baked
fucking concept of bad fucking meeting.
You talking to your manager,
you need guts saying don't do it.
You end up fucking doing it.
I mean,
the way they executed that
in the pilot was just,
it was off the charts tenant 10 out of 10,
as far as old freckles is concerned.
But anyways, Billy crystal has
been going to these clippers games.
I remember I went, I went to a, um,
a clippers games that they have the
old La sports arena. He was there,
the black dude from a different world.
Remember the guy who wore the glasses
probably had some weird name for his
character that fucking killed his
career, like cockroach. You know,
anytime you get one of those names, you're
fucking done, right Dougie. Not Dougie.
He actually got out of it.
Jesus Christ.
How the fuck do you pull
out of the mud Dougie? Um,
Urkel you fucked cockroach.
You fucked. It's another one.
Screech.
Get done.
If anybody is getting into the act of
game, I will tell you this right now.
If you fucking do,
turn it down.
If your character just has a
nickname, you're fucked. You fucked.
Unless you have the,
the,
the talent to start writing your own
shit and producing your own shit.
Then you can get out of it.
You can get out of it,
but your whole fucking life you'd
done right. My out of my mind.
Oh, go fuck yourself. I don't know. I
don't know what I'm saying here. Anyways,
so anyways,
so I go to the La sports arena and it was
Allen Iverson's rookie year and I went
down there,
um,
to watch a game and biggie smalls was in
the crowd and that was the trip within
like five days.
He was dead on that trip and I fucking
walked right by him and he sorta had like
these security guys around, but he's
just sort of standing there hanging out.
And I remember that thinking like,
wow,
I guess that whole East Coast West
thing is a west coast thing is over.
But anyways, Billy crystal was there,
um, the fuck am I talking about?
I don't get it back.
So last night we were at the bar and I'm
sitting there trying to enjoy the game
and we got into this fucking,
we got to like three of the
loudest sports arguments.
I just remember seeing the bartenders
and Knoxville just sitting there laughing
at us is we're screaming at each other
about shit that they didn't even care
about. I remember one point, this guy
came up, he had a red sox shirt on.
And first he just goes, he goes,
how you'll red sox fan down here?
And the guy goes, I'm from Boston.
And then, you know, fuck the Yankees.
And then they get in this big fight and
then in the end versus going, you know,
what the fuck you guys yelling
at me for? It's like, firstly,
you started with the guy. And he goes,
no, I didn't. He walked up to me and said,
hey, fuck the Yankees. It's like, Paul,
you're not wearing anything that says
Yankees on it. You started with Tim,
this guy's wearing a red sox.
Teesha and he'd gone, I did.
You know that level drunk you are where
you just fucking, you ignore everything,
all types of logic.
Um,
so all I'm trying to do is enjoy
it. And the, the fucking assholes,
they won't get off Blake Griffin's back
when we met him, I had, in my mind,
they're going, ah, we're not saying,
we're not saying he's not a perennial
all star. We're not saying that you know,
he, he's not a, he's not a good player.
We're just saying that he should be
doing more. It's like, I don't know.
What you just listed was pretty fucking
impressive, wasn't it? I don't know.
Fucking know. All right, let's,
let's, let's do a little bit of a,
still a little bit of advertising
media. All right. Draft, draft kings,
everybody draft kings.
The wait is finally over.
Baseball season is here at last.
Oh Great.
And the excitement
continues@allseasonlongatdraftkings.com
the official daily
Fantasy Patna of major league baseball.
Shame on you.
Daily fantasy means no season long
commitments, just instant cash,
instant gratification. Why wait until the
end of the season, everybody to clean,
to claim victory when you can win
huge cash every day at draft kings,
that's like a brand new season.
Every time you play,
just select two pictures and a positional
players stay under the salary cap and
you could be on your way to an
enormous pay day. They've actually,
every time I read that, that
sounds actually, you know,
oh, he's on my fantasy team.
The fact that you're actually selecting
this thing and he got to stay under the
cap.
And just how there's some math
nerd that figured that out,
actually sat down,
you know,
and figured out like the fact that you
have to stay under the cap, you know,
on the roulette wheel.
Those are the two green numbers that
tip it and draft kings favor, you know,
but you still going to show up.
You still think you're going to be right
because you are that man right there.
All right.
Last year Peter from Colorado
won 1 million bucks at
draftkings and one day just
playing fantasy baseball.
Some other guy named Chris is
sucking Dick in a bus station.
It's all how you gamble.
Hundreds of thousands of fantasy sports
fans just like you have already cashed
in@draftkings.com. Now it's your turn. Um,
hurry to draft kings.com now and enter
the Promo Code Defense d f e n s e to
play for free.
You could win part of 300 part of the
$300 million prizes being awarded this
season.
Use Promo code defense for entry.
now@draftkings.com draftkings.com
that's draft kings.com.
That actually sounds like a pretty
fucking cool way to watch baseball. No,
actually I get a little
schizophrenia because she's
still not watching the games.
You want you the guys,
I don't know.
All I know is anybody who plays
fantasy football, fantasy baseball,
by the end of one season they
could actually announce the game.
They know so much about
the players. Um, all right.
Oh me undies. Every buddy, me undies,
me undies, no more sweaty balls.
Me undies, me undies. You wear
them right through the fall.
We're up your nuts on some wet leaves.
Stick on the underwear.
It's like a sleeve. It dries out
your balls. Then you feel good.
Then you get your Dick sucked. Oh yeah.
When you're wearing some fucking undies.
Alright me undies,
90%.
That's the percent of your
life that you're in your
underwear and your underwear.
It gets old fast. You know that feeling
of putting on old saggy underwear,
you know, it's like if your
grandmother's arms where your ball bag,
that's what it feels like.
You need to know the feeling of great
fitting underwear that is two times softer
than cotton. You need to know about
me. undies.com Mondays, Mondays,
no more sweaty clamps.
Me undies is the most
comfortable underwear you will
ever wear and it's insane
how good they make you feel.
They fit perfectly.
They don't ride up on you
and they literally pull
moisture away from your skin
so you stay cool. I have
mine on right now. Do I? No.
I need to order more.
They're actually,
I actually really like them because they
don't ride up on me and I don't have
sweaty balls, but if I ever, if I
ever was going to have sweaty balls,
it wouldn't be a problem with me undies.
Mandy's keep in that left
and right real dry. Um,
I have mine on right now and I am
floating. That's what I'm supposed to say.
They have cool styles for both men and
women and they look great. Check them,
check out the photos yourself at me.
undies.com you fucking Weirdo.
This quality would typically retail for
two times. To me. Undies. Price. No.
Retail middleman means more savings.
See you here. I'll make it easy for you.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash burr and
get 20% off your first order and free
shipping. Save even more.
When you buy a pack of them,
they guarantee you're going to be happy
with them or your first pair is free.
All right. And lastly,
not lastly, but leastly.
But this is the last one in this little
chunk here. Um, trunk club. Everybody.
Guys, you might hate shopping, but
you still want to look good, right?
What if you could snap your fingers and
have a trunk full of clothes that fit
perfectly and make you look amazing?
You're going to love what gets delivered
to you from Trunk club@trunkclub.com
slash burr.
Your answer,
you answer a few simple questions
about your look style and size. Well,
kind of a free spirit. Um,
I like to play video games.
A little shy. Look at your turtleneck.
You pull it up over your face. Um,
anyways.
Then the next email,
they ship you a trunk full of fresh
new clothes right to your door.
You're try them on.
You keep what you want is send back what
you don't in the prepaid box. That's it.
A better wardrobe than you could ever
pick out for yourself in minutes and you
don't have to go down to the
GDF and mall that I mentioned.
The services free your stylist
that the shopping the box,
even the shipping all 100% free.
When you go to trunk club.com/burr
only pay for the clothes.
You keep no ongoing subscriptions,
no hidden charges,
no GDF and malls. Do you realize
this? You just going to tell them why,
what you like to where
they're going to send you it.
You keep what you want and then you send
it back and you just pay for what you
kept. You live in like a celebrity,
like you have your own Goddamn stylists.
They never had this shit when I was a kid.
I had to go down there and walked
through that sea of humanity.
Just great clothes
handpicked for your style.
My listeners have used trunk club and
you know what they give everybody?
Everybody's giving back great
reviews. All right, you're gonna,
you're gonna thank me on this and
right now it's completely free.
So get started@trunkclub.com
slash birth today.
That's trunk club.com/birth Jesus Christ.
Could I be,
could I be making your lives any easier?
Run for your law.
Anyways, let's get back to the shit.
I'll tell you this right now, man and I,
one of the most depressing places I've
ever been to is the u s airway terminal
connecting out of Charlotte,
North Carolina.
I was taking the red eye in.
Oh my God.
The fucking humanity that I saw.
Oh my God. People just
sitting there, you know,
guy comes in with the, I'd been smoking
fucking cigarettes my whole life.
You know what? The tubes up his
nose carrying an oxygen tank.
Somebody else sitting there,
you know, with a plate of
Nachos, right? And right now,
lap, beautiful girl just sitting there
killing herself, just eaten poison.
Everybody just poisoning themselves. It
was like a fight. There was like this,
like this mass suicide that was going
on as I sat there and the term or not,
nobody making a fucking quality choice.
Everybody just choosing
misery in the future.
I don't even get me started with
the fucking shoes. I was really as,
I was like going, wow man, this is
this, this is flying to Savannah.
Then I realized like, Nah, you know,
some of them are going to other places.
It was really depressing, you know,
that's how that days, you know,
it was coming to a close,
but then you know the wonders of the road.
Next thing you know,
I walk to a bar and I'm with Jay and I'm
getting a ride home from a gay guy in a
kilt. I mean, you know, you always hold
out hope that it's going to turn around
if he's listening,
thank you for the ride and thank you for
putting the beer in the fucking paper
cups. It was, it was tremendous. What a
night, right? Oh, so we ended up going,
we ended up going out to this speakeasy.
Right. You know, which is, you know,
it's just a fame thing right now. The
key, we met these two fucking women.
They work for like the uh, Savannah PD or
whatever. So now we'll get you in, right?
So we all fucking head over there and
was sitting in this bar then making some
good drinks and everything.
And I wish I had these two ladies on
the podcast because I was just grilling
them. I was like, what is,
what is the fucking weirdest?
I go, don't tell me any of the sad
ones when people are calling the cops.
Give me the weird ones. The weirdest
one. This one woman told me it was,
somebody said that their neighbor was
jerking off and they could smell the
semen. And she goes, Oh, you
know, okay, so what do you mean?
Like is he standing in the window?
Can you see him? She goes, no,
I can't see them, but I can smell
it. I can smell it through the walls.
They had to send somebody over
there. So when he goes, all right,
you could smell it. I
got to tell you, ma'am,
I don't want to start an argument here,
but I cannot smell any ges. You know,
I think you have a
wonderful home here and uh,
maybe you ought to get some
medication. Um, but anyways,
uh, so thank you to everybody who
came out to Savannah, by the way.
And everybody who came out to Knoxville,
the fucking theater I played in Knoxville,
I think rightly said,
Ralphie may did a special there and I
can see why it's one of most beautiful
theaters I've ever been to. It was, um,
the Tennessee theater built in 1927 or 28.
You know,
just this unbelievably gorgeous place
where you used to go down to watch movies.
You know, I swear to God, if I
could be alive back in the day,
like I think I would go back to when
they first built a lot of these theaters
that I played in just to watch movies.
No one,
everybody gets dressed up and
it's like a real big fucking deal.
And they had this giant Wurlitzer organ
and I forgot to look for the thing and
find out where it was.
They got it refurbished,
send it out to some maniac in Reno
that redid the whole God damn thing.
He's like a,
he's like the guy,
I guess if you're going to have you
fucking giant Wurlitzer organ redone.
And um, the crowd was, uh,
was phenomenal. You know,
it was hilarious was we were
fucking, uh, on the way.
Their law had such a big basketball fan.
He wanted to fuck and
he wanted to do,
he wanted to go see like the Tennessee
volunteers trophy case. See Pat Summit,
you know,
trophies like women's basketball.
That's like how psycho into
fucking basketball he is. And uh,
he ended up,
he ended up doing this pat summit joke
on the bus that had us die and laughing
but like verse, he goes, Dude, you got
to do that on stage. And I said, Jay,
don't do that on stage. Don't do that
on stage. This is like their fucking,
this is like their female Jesus,
you don't do that. Don't do it.
Dementia joke on there. And then what's
his verse? He goes, he should do it.
So I said, all right, do it tonight.
Okay. And I go in, if it fucking bombs,
all you got to do to save it is
just, it was basically a, you know,
she's got dementia. It's like, well,
if you saw that much women's
basketball over the years, you know,
you'd want to forget about it to
write a silly joke as silly joke.
But if you say it in Knoxville,
it's going to be a problem.
Or if there's some current who blogs,
they'll,
they'll fucking flip out about it.
And the,
where my grandfather has dementia and you
made me sad Monday morning podcast tee
shirt, right? And then, then all of a
sudden there'll be a controversy, right?
Fucking baby seals starving to death,
washing up on the fucking sand.
They're going to fucking give a shit
about a joke. Somebody told Knoxville.
So anyways,
so he was supposed to go out,
he was supposed to go out there and just
do the fucking joke. And if it bombed,
I go. Just say, Hey, I gotta be honest
with you. You know, for, as he said,
don't do it. But first he said,
do it. Bert said, don't do it.
I learned something here next time,
listen to the headline or
something cute like that.
So he guts to go doing it
and he does that shit first.
Go on. I don't know, I'd said this
joke on the bus and that are now,
I don't know if I should say.
And the crowds, like God said,
like he totally got him into it and
it bugged me because then it ended up
working and then he said verse,
he's right. It's like now you, well,
once you did the fucking UNICEF
speech before the joke, you know,
you almost questioning that goddamn
comedy manhood about whether they're going
to laugh about it or not. But uh, anyways,
I'm just breaking that balls. Where,
when a good time out here.
So, hey, Chattanooga people,
if you listen to this today,
let us know what there is to do out here.
I never been here. This is fucking cool.
This tour, because I've only
ever been in Nashville. And, um,
we actually drove up from Savannah
on the bus and it was so beautiful.
One point going through some
of these, um, national parks.
I was actually sitting up front for like
John Madden on my way to green bay for
a game or something. I was sitting up
there absolutely eastern Tennessee,
south east of Knoxville, fucking
God's country. I'm telling you,
Tony, if you can just deal
with them, fucking hillbillies
out there and you know,
every once in a while somebody is going
to, they are going to be coming for you.
You know, I don't know
what goes on out there. Um,
I could never get me to live out there.
She's a city girl. You know what I mean?
The way I get nervous on a subway, she
gets nervous when she sees the woods. So,
uh, you know the deal, you know who's
going to make her more miserable?
She's gonna make me more miserable. She
went, so we stay in the fucking city,
stay in a city, in a state where we
are going to be out of water in a year.
How funny is it that I just put it in
an immaculate bathroom at my house,
spent all my fucking money on it.
Didn't spare any expense we'll put was
already probably not going to make my
money back because they're just going
to look at it as square footage anyways.
And I added no square
footage to my fucking house.
MMM.
But at least I had this great
fucking shower, you know?
And now we're going to be out of water.
And once again,
nobody seems to be a alarmed by it.
Nobody seems to be talking about it.
Like what? What exactly is going on?
You know,
population seals washing up
fucking running out of water.
Everybody just stay in the course.
I think that's the game plan.
I think that is the game plan. You just
fucking act like everything is fine.
And then one day you just take that
asteroid to the face and it's over.
Maybe that's the way to do
it. I'm starting to give
into it, you know, fuck it.
You know, y'all, I can't do
anything about it, but fuck.
He call you don't go home. Do
you go kill yourself? Pick,
put it on a spit.
You won't dig a hole.
We don't cook a picked day. I want to
go to a fucking pig pickin down here.
Oh, by the way, uh, when we go to New
Orleans, a, the Pelicans are playing,
the fucking warriors come out and play.
I think we're going to try and go to the
game. We've got a day off down there.
How fucking cool is that? Um, but
anyways, I absolutely love Knoxville man.
Um, and I have to get back there
again. The crowd was awesome.
I have got to get back there for a game.
Um,
and I was asking him what game to go
to and everybody was go, you know,
go to the Tennessee, Georgia game.
Uh, they play Oklahoma next year.
That'll be a good game.
And then this fucking old time
I came up to me and he's like,
game you want to go to is the Alabama
game. And I was just like, right there.
All right, that's the game we're going
to go to. Why wouldn't I go to it?
That might be my goal.
I'm going to go to what every sec team
when they play Alabama and root against
Alabama because it's just,
it's just so much fun to root against
those fucking guys and screamed.
The dream ends tonight. You know why
bill, why do you give a shit about it?
I really don't. I just like being
a cunt. I'm telling you guys,
I'm going to retire and I'm going to buy
a house in Alabama. That's my game plan.
That is my exit strategy. You know,
God willing, we still have water.
When I retire,
somehow in La and my house is actually
worth something and it hasn't turned to
dust, I am then going to go out.
I'm going to buy me a spread.
Maybe eastern Tennessee,
you know,
it'd be far enough inland
that those fucking hurricanes
will slow down. You know,
maybe every once in a while there's
a micro burst and the trees lay down.
But I'm inside. I'm a nice
brick house. Brick House.
All right, let's get to some of the
questions here. Uh, um, for this week.
Oh, by the way, um, for the, for
the Thursday, Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast.
Just before Friday. Um,
if you would like, do you know stuff
that you want me to talk about?
Articles for me to read, videos,
questions, any of that shit.
You do it through Twitter and have the
Hashtag t a m m p tango Alpha Mike,
Mike, Papa. Sorry. Anyways,
I'm just Hashtag or is that,
and I'll fucking scroll through at two
seconds before he start and you'll get to
listen to me read out loud. All right.
Factory made diamonds. Okay, bill,
this is a followup from Thursday clip
where you answered a question about real
diamonds versus fake ones and whether
or not women should be cool with the
factory made ones.
Uh,
please ask listeners to go back and
check it out if they haven't already.
All right, we'll go back and listen
to that. I guess it was last week.
I don't even remember
talking about this shit. Uh,
a a big Billy dildo.
I was listening to your clip.
MMM.
You replayed on the just checking it.
Oh, well from last week. Oh, that's why,
because it was what? It was a
throwback clip from last Thursday's.
Just checking in on your Thursday
afternoon, just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast. Um, he said,
I know what this magical stone is.
Okay,
all right. I'll tell you the name, but you
can choose to skip over it if you want.
If you don't want the secret to get out,
it's called a,
I can't even say it.
Moist Sinai.
M. O. I. S. S. A. N. I. T. E.
It's not actually an
exact diamond replica,
but it looks identical to everyone
that isn't trained to know difference.
The good news is that your secret
amongst amongst dudes can be safe.
The only way to tell the difference is
if you take it to a jeweler to figure it
out. If it's a dude, they're not going
to fucking rat you out. If it's a check,
well then you've got a
wildcard aren't your hands,
but there's nothing you
can do at that point.
I just know I'll do metal work in jewelry
stores are also cons because they're
going to want, because they're going to be
like, oh yeah, he bought you a fake one.
And because they know that the woman's
going to go home and fucking loser shit
and the guy is going to come back with
his tail between his legs bringing the
God damn bag of cash to buy a real one.
Um, I'm going say, okay, so I can't,
I can't even pronounce it
moist, Moist Sinai. Um,
he wrote it all basically
in lowercase letters,
so I don't know where to accent
that word. It's m o, I s s a N. I t.
E for guys who need to buy their
woman in an engagement ring.
But you don't want to blow a
bunch of money on diamonds,
just get them one of this
and they'll never know.
That's actually a great thing too,
to see if he got a gold digging whore.
She actually goes down and checks it out,
like immediately to see what it's worth.
Sexy. You already fucking leaving me.
What are you doing here?
Right. Um, all right. He said,
I just bought one for my girl last week.
Actually I looked up the exact diamond
equivalent and it was between 6,500 to
seven grand just for the diamond.
I paid 750 bucks.
The best news is that my girl is totally
on board with this idea and her idea
was to pocket the extra to go on a
bad ass honeymoon. Yeah, absolutely.
And then if somebody fucking goes,
you know,
gimme a fucking diamond ring or your life,
you just give it to me,
go Christ,
that's fucking brilliant.
Uh, you know what?
You should have counterfeit cash in your
wallet to just walk around everything
fake. I love this. By the way, you know,
made up that thing about spending
three months salary on a ring.
The fucking diamond companies,
of course they did.
They had a whole marketing
campaign around it,
so they're really fucking you over on,
on top of the fact that they
have a fucking monopoly so
they can charge whatever
the fuck they want for real
diamonds. It's a total sham. Anyways,
just wanted to spread the word and
let other dudes know that there is an
alternative that makes both the
girl and your bank account happy.
Go Fuck Yourself. You know what, the
more I hear about all of this stuff,
best thing ever, it's gotta be
real estate. You know what I mean?
You can walk up to it, you can
touch it, you can live in it.
Obviously if you've got a building on
it that's just gotta be the way to go.
You know, fucking stock market. I have
shares in this. Oh yeah, where are they?
You got them in your pocket.
You know,
I am a firm believer of um,
investing shit that you could just end
shit that you could walk up and touch.
But now with the diamonds, I dunno,
that's the whole diamond gain.
Now, if you, if you buy
into the diamond game now,
you have to that the,
the people at the top,
the evil doers actually,
uh, keep that monopoly.
Cause if they don't and you get
free enterprise going on there,
then then what do you have if you get
like sprint starts digging for diamonds,
right? Nokia and all these other cons.
And then what happens? You've got to,
you got to shit storm on your hands.
I swear to God people,
I'm going to buy an apartment building.
I'm going to become a slum Lord.
That's what I'm doing. I'm going to
buy apartment buildings, fixed them up,
read them out to people, and then I'm
going to slowly back out of this business.
I want to retire the way Sinatra
did the first time. That's my goal.
I don't know if I'll be able to do it,
but I would love the way he did it.
He's singing this song and he just goes,
excuse me while I disappear,
was the final loan line of the science
of Jesus Christ the final line of the
song,
the final long and assign the final
line of the song. There we go.
And um, it's for that pet. So
joke, look at me. I'm already
losing my mind here. Um,
and he just stepped out of
the spotlight dis that if he,
if he fucking left that way.
Come on man,
that's even better than if Jordan left
after he hit that shot against Utah.
I know I've already talked about this,
but I am obsessed with how to get out of
his business now as I've hit the middle
part of my career,
I feel 23 years ago,
I was 23 at 20 almost
24 23 years from now,
I'm going to be 70 just like that. Boom.
Fucking over. What am I going to be doing?
Huh?
70 years old,
you read the religion at that point they
put you out to pasture in fucking Vegas
or you're on cruise ships, but
either way, either way, they're like,
let's do you just stay right here,
their grandpa and we'll bring
the people to you. Fuck that.
Okay.
Fucked up. I'm going to buy a bunch.
I'm going to become a slum Lord.
I'm going to buy a bunch of
fucking apartment buildings
in the middle of nowhere
and I'm going to buy a white on
white suit, put on some weight,
and just look like boss Hog,
right?
A redheaded fucking boss Hog and I'm
going to walk around a white hat,
you know, and a big cigar that I never
liked. That's what I'm going to do.
There's actually some people that you
know who ended up great fucking retirement
out of this business.
The smothers brothers and what they
told me you were at the Orleans casino,
both of those guys,
they started their own a winery and a,
they have their own vineyard
and all that type of stuff,
and they got that thing going up
where it was making enough money to,
you know what's so cool about them?
When they retired,
they didn't even tell
people they were retiring.
They just did their last
show and they just left
total fucking class act, no
begging, no hat and the hand,
they'll fucking cry and no being broke.
They had their money.
They had a good fucking time.
They were done with.
They left and now they're sitting
on a fucking vineyard. Jesus Christ.
You fucking tell somebody, let me ask
you this. What's your guys game plant?
If you weigh,
what's your fantasy?
My fantasy is that I somehow fucking,
I dunno,
have enough money in real estate rental
properties or something. I don't know.
I'm just spit balling here,
right?
That you're actually making as much
in rent as you were doing your job.
So then you can quit your job and
just seamlessly walk over to that.
You can just be like, yeah, I'm
not working anymore. You know,
you got all your building's paid for.
You got all your things rented.
Everybody's cool. I know this isn't
going to happen. This is a fantasy.
And then the check just
comes in, right? You fucking,
you go live the middle of fucking
nowhere where it's cheap as hell.
No property tax,
no nothing.
Get a giant ass fucking TV.
All the sports packages,
right?
Get yourself a fucking book on, uh,
on how to eat Vegan or some shit.
So you stay in shape telling you and
then every night you just get shit.
Be fucking tremendous. Tremendous.
That's what I want to do.
I got to do it like that.
I can't be like these athletes that I
see that go around fucking acting like
jerk off sell whole career. Then they're
like, oh fuck, I'm in my final contract.
What am I going to deal with? And they
just keep playing and playing and playing.
Fucking try on half the
fucking jerseys in the league.
That ain't going to be making,
you know,
just like Paulie in Goodfellas, that
guy's going to die in jail. Okay.
Then ain't going to me. They ain't
gonna be me. Hey, smarten up. Right.
I hope that didn't hurt here. It's like
it just did mine. All right. Let me, uh,
get onto the next thing here.
Um, alright. Ditched Bio lady.
All right.
A dear old Billy freckles.
I had a date tonight with a lady and the
plan was to go get dinner and then see
it concert.
She was really cool and we went out to
a good restaurant near my apartment.
Dinner went well. I was making her laugh,
et cetera. And after I paid the check,
I told her I had to use the bathroom.
She said she would,
she wait right outside the restaurant.
So I went in and did my thing,
but when I came out I couldn't find her.
I had only taken a piss.
So it's not like I was taking
a long time in the bathroom.
I called her and it went
straight to voicemail.
Then I waited around and texted her and
she said that she had to leave because
her friend's boyfriend had just broken
up with her and that she needed to go
back to the apartment right
away. Uh, Jesus Christ really?
And she couldn't wait
to say goodbye to you.
I asked her if she couldn't have at least
told me before she left and she said
she was sorry. We both have tickets
to go see a concert next week,
which we had planned a before we planned,
but I think it's just going to be really
awkward and I don't want to do, uh,
and I don't know what to do because
I'm pretty sure she just ditch me.
I would love to hear your Boston
accent. Give me some advice. Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself. Um,
yeah, you either got discharge.
She's unbelievably fucking rude. But
yeah, you can't hit your wagon to,
this is no way.
There's no way you're putting a baby in
that the fuck you have a baby. You know,
when all of a sudden you know, she
squirts it out and you're like, oh my God,
look at it honey.
She fucking takes off again.
Yeah, you can't have that.
She's, she, she, I dunno. I don't know
what her fucking deal is, but why,
what all I need to do right now,
right now. Okay. You and this woman,
it's fucking over.
Okay.
And your be your best hope
if you still want a Banger,
is to stick by your guns that you,
that you don't put up with the shit that
it's fucking over and just be a matter
of fact. Just say no. That was really
rude. And I was also very immature.
If you weren't having a good
time, he should have just
said something. Um, there,
no, no, no. My girl fan boy.
And then, and then on top of
that, you lie to me. I mean,
I'm actually glad that all
of this happened because I
was able to see you know,
that you're not the kind of person that
I would want to be in a relationship
with.
You know, that fucks
with them. Wait a minute.
He's not mesmerized by my pussy anymore.
Right.
Next thing you know, she's riding. Yeah.
These are all just fantasies. People.
I don't know if there's any of this
shit's true. Um, all right, so wait,
does she have one ticket
and you have one ticket?
Okay.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the math is on a ticky said,
we both have tickets to go to
the show. Well, here's the deal.
If you have both the tickets,
okay,
then you just take somebody else.
MMM.
Yeah. And I don't even think you'll, you
don't think you over a phone call either,
do you? Or maybe you do. Yeah,
maybe do. I would just call
him. Just say, yeah, listen,
I'm taking somebody's, ah,
no, no, no. Don't do that.
If she has the tickets, sell,
tell it. If you keep them,
keep them. Yeah. I don't know.
This thing is over, dude. You don't
need me. You know what the deal is?
It's fucking over.
Yeah.
I gotta be honest. It's fucking hilarious
that she just left. I've done that.
I did that when I was young and immature.
I did that one time.
I met this woman and she wanted
to go out and go see this band.
And so we went out there and
next thing you know,
she was up on the stage dancing
while the band was playing,
pointing at the crowd as if
she was in the band. And um,
I didn't have the emotional maturity to
wait till she got off the stage to be
like, uh, yeah. I don't know what that
was. It seemed like you were enjoying it,
but, um, it, uh, you know, I'm going to go
and, you know, I, I just
left and I'll tell you this,
I regret doing that because I think it
was really mean of me to do that to her,
if that's how she likes having a good
time and likes going up there and dancing
in front of a band that
she's in and you know,
in front of a group that she's not in
pointing at the crowd is if she wrote the
song, if that's what the fuck
she likes to do, then, you know,
okay.
I guess, you know, I should
have let her do that. I was, uh,
the very least, they should have been a
man enough to fucking walk away. So, um,
trying to think is anybody. Yeah,
I've had a woman do that to me too.
I don't want more. One time was totally
into me. It was over. It was a lay up.
She was going to bang me and I went up
and I had a bad set and I got off and she
was gone.
I bombed so bad that a woman who was
willing to have sex with me thought better
of it.
And this is the best part.
It was a festival and it
was only a 15 minutes set.
Okay.
In 15 minutes.
15 and I have to think that halfway
through my set, because I got off stage,
she was gone.
So about seven minutes in,
she did a one 80 and just fucking
walked out. So it came back to me.
Oh, it always comes back to you. All
right. Crime that pays your bill.
If you could get away with any,
with a major crime, which would, uh,
which would you be more proud of?
A bank heist and art,
robbery and assassination of an evil world
leader. Oh, assassination all day long.
That was the first thing I thought of.
That was the first thing I thought of
that if you went to like the last supper
of every dose, making people's lives
miserable, you know, pretending like,
you know, they don't have, they know
those people who buy up patents,
so we can't get, um, energy,
electricity and gas and
all that shit easier.
People who just fucking get in the way
of that progress, rape the environment,
fuck over poor people, all of
those, they all go to the same meal.
Yeah.
All right. And you just fucking, I dunno,
Yoga and like some photo or some shit
with one of those guns that they have on
like a fucking, I dunno,
you ever see that one?
That was an Argo when they went down the
runway and they had that machine gun on
that fucking jeep,
whatever and m 60 southern people are
tearing their fucking heroin right now
cause they know exactly what I was like,
Hey, I'm sick day made an f 60 16 years.
It's an AMD 60, 80 this point buddy. Um,
and you just fucking mow them down.
You just mow him down and it's old and
then all of a sudden, and then what bill,
then who's going to run us?
Cause I know it's not going to be me.
Then somehow decent people all take those
jobs and make the right decisions and
everybody's fucking chill and there's
enough for everybody and everybody can
relax.
Okay.
All right.
That's what I would do. Um, I would
never do an art robbery because
I don't have an appreciation
for a lot of it,
especially if it's just a
bunch of scribbles, you know,
if it looks like a sleeve tattoo or yeah,
somebody kind of call it
in your arm there, buddy.
I can kind of see a bird spider web.
I don't know what else is there. Um,
a bank heist. I don't want
to do that because, uh,
that fucks with regular people's money,
you know, art, robbery, then, you know,
next scene or Butler's out of a job.
Yeah. I probably shouldn't have said that.
I had assassinated evil word leader
probably put me on some fucking list,
you know,
just added to the fucking audio that they
have been the fucking basement of the
Pentagon. Um, it all, it all
ends up. Y'All end up, you know,
you just end up in a worker camp. I think
that's how it goes from here on out.
All right.
Roll the dice.
Dear bill and my wife has a friend
who we've known for a long time and it
happens to be very attractive.
Let me read this again. My wife's.
Yeah,
my wife's, you have more
than one wife here, buddy.
My wife has a friend who
we've known for a long time.
It happens to be very attractive. Okay,
so you've already rubbed one out to her,
possibly thought about or why
you're banging your wife. Okay.
The other day over a couple
of drinks with my wife,
she admits that she wants to experience
a threesome and she wants it to be with
us. Oh, Jesus.
No.
Oh my God. Here we go. Here we go. Jesus,
we should have closed with this question.
This, this is a close bid right here.
When my wife first tells me this,
you can imagine my excitement,
but then she adds the kicker,
her friend while confessing,
um,
her desire for threesome ads that
she has genital herpes bump on.
Wow.
I did not see that left turn coming,
but she swears that it is dormant
and we're not at risk. Well,
how do you think she got it?
Okay.
Oh, that's such a stupid thing to say.
Maybe she fucks him guy. Well, you know,
you always have to fucking, you know,
look out for the women in these,
maybe she fucks him.
Douchebags scum bag guy.
Like you've seen their fucking dig on
a billboard out in La. It, it says,
do you trust him? And there's a
guy laying there with his shift,
the look on his face with this woman
looking at him, HIV positive, you know,
type of thing. Well they would never
have a billboard. Do you trust her?
It's unfucking believable. Like you know,
I saw to time one of these magazines,
right where it says, uh, you know,
reasons women cheat top 10 reasons women
cheat in the top eight out of 10 was
were because of Gat was was
something that guy was doing.
It's fucking unbelievable. Anyways,
plowing ahead. I am close to your age.
So I asked you,
do you roll the dice and go for it
knowing that this may be your last shot of
the threesome or do you play it safe
and politely declined the offer?
Thanks and go fuck yourself in
parentheses with protection.
Uh, no dude, you can't. You can't do that.
You cannot do that because right now
you're going to have a fucking threesome.
All right? Even if you did, it's going to
make it weird between you and your wife.
It just is. As much as you're going to
try to be cool, it's, it's, you know,
you'll be cool with it. She won't
be on some level. She won't be,
you fucking moaned a little
too much with the other one.
It's going to be a fucking shit show.
All right? And then on top of that,
you're on, or you're going to be reminded
once a goddamn month that you did it.
Fuck that. Fuck Carla. That
all right. This is the deal.
All right? If your wife is
willing to fucking do it, that,
why don't you do it with somebody who's a,
you know what I mean?
Who doesn't have any prior
convictions here? All right.
Get somebody with a clean
slate and, um, but um, I dunno,
I'm sort of a firm believer that
you can't do that with your wife.
You do that with somebody that you're
not going to be married to. I just think,
uh, you know, I don't know.
You ever see that shit when people like
fucking drink too much water and they
die cause like the, the, the walls
of their cells like burst open.
Like that's what I think happens when
you have a threesome with your wife and
somebody else. And it's basically the
lining to your relationship. It's fucking,
it's split. It's done, it's
over. Right. And then it becomes,
then her next thing is going to be
like, well, let's do it again this time.
Can we do it with a guy and a,
well now I want to do what a fucking guy
because there's nothing in it for me.
You know what I mean? What the fuck? Well,
there was nothing if fuck you,
you enjoy the women can enjoy other women,
you know, and you get into that, well
that's a double fucking standard. I go,
suck a dick already. Leave me out of it.
I'll be downstairs. You know, you just,
you just walking into
that whole fucking world.
MMM Jesus Christ.
But you know, you gotta give it up to
this woman for just being totally upfront.
Gee, I mean that, look,
there's something going on.
The fact that you're excited by this
and not shocked and that your wife is
willing to do it.
All right?
You guys all seem like this is
all pretty loosey Goosey here.
I Dunno dude. Even with protection,
they see you can still get it, dude.
Fuck that. I don't know.
I, I wouldn't do it.
I would politely decline
and then ask for references if she hasn't
anybody she knows that doesn't have
herpes as wants to do it. I don't, I don't
know what to tell you here, buddy. Um,
okay.
I would say don't listen to your Dick.
What would you tell a friend of
yours if they were in that position?
Oh my God.
I guess the question I haven't
asked is how hot is this woman?
Is it worth the risk?
I don't know.
You don't want it is I, I
just, I can't get beyond like,
what is the conversation afterwards?
Okay.
You Guys Bang. First of all, do
not bang in your own fucking house.
Okay? You want to walk away from that
crime scene. You understand? All right?
But then you gotta be thinking like,
okay, then you get in the car now.
Fuck that.
You got to have that,
you know that awkward goodbye.
Oh my God.
Yeah, that was, that was
fun. Hopefully it went well.
Hopefully you don't get so excited,
sir. That you fucking, uh, you know,
you get a false start there.
Right.
Let's just hope the whole fucking
thing goes well. And then he got,
he got that ride home in the
car. Yeah. You both get in there.
You're both trying to make you don't
want is, you don't know what to say.
So you just making noises like
sitting down and like, Heh,
putting on the radio.
He looked like a yeah.
Got a new Costco down here. Huh? You know,
God knows where the fuck her head's at.
I'll tell you this right now.
There's no fucking way.
She's not going to ask some questions.
So you know,
like what are you thinking
right now? Oh, I would,
we normally think and I'm thinking,
fuck, you don't even start this shit.
This is the thing. I think you have
to have that conversation beforehand.
If you're going to do it, you gotta say
to your wife, all right, here's the deal.
We're going to do this shit, but no being
fucking weird afterwards. All right,
none of this did you like it? And he lent
jai hair my then meet and none of that.
That's all off the table. All
right, then what are you then?
Then she's sitting on it and then you know
what she do? Then she'll start crying.
You know,
I know.
I'm just presenting the worst
case scenario or even worse.
She fucking loves it and
wants to do it all the time.
And then that just leads to just, ah,
it's just going to lead the other shit.
It's gonna lead the other shit. I Dunno.
I Dunno. Who knows? It could be fun,
could be fun. I just presented all the
hazards that could possibly happen.
Who knows? Man, you can fucking
go do it. Bang, Bang, bomb.
You guys never fucking talk about it
again. You get to check that off the list.
You know, you stare at your
Dick for a good 30 to 60 days.
Nothing looks funny down there. And
you know what? You got away with it.
Just like Woody Allen and
crime and punishment, right?
You just sort of get away with it. Who
knows? Maybe it happens, I don't know.
All right? And with that,
stamps.com everybody,
a lot of small businesses get stuck
doing this, doing things the old way,
just out of habit, including vital
operations like mailing and shipping.
That can be so time consuming. If you're
still making trips to the post office,
you need stamps.com with stamps.com you
could do all your mailing and shipping
right from your desk.
Never go to the post office again with
stamps.com print postage for any letter
or package using your own
computer or a printer.
Then I hand it to your mail
carrier or drop it in the mailbox.
stamps.com is a convenient,
it's convenient and easy to use,
and it will save you money. You'll get
a special po, uh, postage discounts.
You can't even get at the post office.
I use stamps.com to send out my posters.
I sent them out the uh, the Billie
Bible belt tour posters. Um,
by the way,
if you come to the show,
all the posters will be autographed and
I'll be coming out after the shows to
personalize them if you would like,
whatever.
I'm trying to sell as many as I can so
I don't have a garage full of a bar.
They have been selling very well.
High quality paper people enjoying them.
That was a commercial within the
commercial. Right now, use my last name,
[inaudible], B U R, r
for this special offer,
no risk trial plus a $110 bonus offer
that includes a digital scale and up to
$55 free postage. Don't wait. Go to
stamps.com before you do anything else,
click
on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinburgerburthatstamps.com
enter burr. And lastly,
but not leastly legal zone,
five things you can count on when
using legal zoom for your business.
You're ready. Number one, reliability.
More than a million people have already
trusted legal zoom to help start their
business. If you're looking to
incorporate form an LLC or nonprofit,
get a DBA or move legal zoom or more
legal zoom can help you get started the
right way. Number two, experience.
They've been helping business owners
with legal challenges for more than a
decade. You can count on legal zoom
for all the details. Number three,
helpful support.
They have the right people on hand to
answer your questions all based in the
United States. Number for legal
advice, since they're not a law firm,
legal zoom built a network of independent
attorneys available in most states.
They can give advice on
the best ways to get added,
plus provide a contract review and other
useful services to help you run your
business. And finally,
number five, no surprise,
legal zoom provides complete transparency
with upfront pricing and customer
reviews.
They have a 100% satisfaction guaranteed.
Make the smart choice for
your business@legalzoom.com
today and don't forget to
enter burpee.
You are a checkout to save even
more legalzoom.com Promo Code Burr.
All right. Let's wrap this thing up
here with the final question. Um,
I know what you guys do. Have
you been watching hockey?
Yes, I have. Yes, I have. Uh,
I've been watching the Ottawa
Montreal series, of course,
rooting against Montreal, um, Ottawa
or giving them a way tougher series.
Then I thought they were going to,
they played great. They just, um,
Montreal is just fucking relentless,
relentless. I can't even talk.
I'm so fucking out of it's
God damn late nights. Um,
they've just been so
fucking relentless and,
uh, I dunno, man.
They had to win. Obviously they had
to win the last game three zero.
I don't see Montreal losing four straight,
although if they do,
mmm.
I will book,
what can I do next week on the podcast?
If they somehow lose four games in a row,
I don't know what I'd do.
It would just be the greatest thing
ever. I wouldn't, I would truly enjoy it,
but then I would get
nervous because we did that.
We blew up three games to
none lead against March, uh,
against the flyers and then the neck.
Very next year we won the Stanley Cup.
So I hope that doesn't happen.
I hope they don't lose four in a row.
Do I? I don't fucking know. What am I
talking about? All right. Mother herb.
Dear Billy Bong rip.
Um,
Monday is four 20,
and I know the Thursday podcast is now
designated towards good vibes, man.
While the Monday morning remains your
bleak outlook on humanity, it really does.
However,
in the spirit of the holiday,
can you please tell us something
crunchy about yourself?
I don't even know what that means.
Perhaps a time when you connected with
nature or saw the human race is won or in
the least tell about a
song or movie you saw. Hi.
That was awesome. I love you. Love Nia.
This guy wrote this when he was
high. Love both of you guys, man. Um,
I do. I always seen the human
race's one. I've always seen it.
That's why it's so fucking
depressing to watch the concert,
the top do what they're doing.
That's why my fantasy is to take all of
'em out and then people who are actually
responsible going and do the job.
When they fix the world and I don't have
to do anything after I'm done pulling
the trigger and my life is totally easy.
Maybe that's selfish.
I don't know what it is.
Maybe I'm an idealist.
You want me to tell you something
crunchy about myself? It's not enough to,
you know that I make pies,
Huh?
From scratch.
Okay.
All right. You know what? I have a
lemon and lime tree in my front yard.
All right.
And I get excited when I walk out there
and I get to pick them off the tree,
you know? And then I bring them in
the house and I go, you know what?
I'm going to make a key
lime pie out of this.
And then I come back later when I
realized that I forgot to tell my wife and
she's fucking used the
limes that I needed. See,
it's still going to go back
to something bleak, you know?
Cause that's what's like physics.
There's a, there's the balance man.
You know what I mean? Man. It's like,
you know when life gives you lemons, you,
your wife's can eat a man and it's just,
you just gotta be all right with Ted man.
He's got to look down at your toes,
wiggle Amenia sandals, and just kind of
wait for the other ones to grow, man.
You know? Um, how was that? Was that fine?
Was that okay?
We're in something crunchy by me.
How about the fact that I'm going out
to all these tertiary cities? Yes.
I just did use that word. Did I
pronounce it correctly? I don't think so.
How about that?
How about I liked going out and fucking
hanging out with the people afterwards.
I actually enjoy people on a one to one
basis if they're not conscious. Right.
I, you know what? You got me,
sir. I think you stumped me.
I don't know that I have anything crunchy.
No. Sorry. I tried.
What do you want from me
baby seals washing up on the fucking
beach has killed me this week.
Is that crunchy enough for you?
Okay.
It's made me not eat fish
the whole fucking week.
I think I might be done with fish. I'm
done eating animals that we can't grow,
you know, breed or whatever.
Even then, I think it's,
I don't know, I go back and forth
with, if it makes me a piece of shit,
if I eat fucking animals or if you know,
they would have gotten eaten anyway.
What the fuck would a cow we doin
if we didn't have a fence around it?
It would be walking around like a big
slow dope and it'll get, you know,
there'd be a fucking mountain lion
around his neck within two seconds.
Just hang in there slowly suffocating
the thing. Well, we got the decency.
They have that ceiling
gun hover over its head
and knock them out so you can get
yourself a prime god damn ribs.
I know there's a lot of questions. I
liked that angle, man. Try to draw it.
The crunchy side of me that
made me really uncomfortable.
There was a nice feeling.
Everyone's so why you got to get
out of your comfort zone? All right,
that's the podcast for this week.
Go fuck yourselves.
I'll check in on you on
Thursday. And, uh, you know what,
I'm rooting for the Tampa Bay lightening
because they have been hab killers.
God knows the Bruins weren't.
So that is my adoptive team.
I haven't watched a second of the fucking
capital's islanders series that seems
like it's going to be a great one.
And I'm loving that the islanders in
their last year in that building, uh,
are going out like champs here, you know,
going down, swinging. If I got the time,
the Games keep coming on the east
coast ones when I have shows.
So I'm in central time now.
Maybe I can watch the first
period of, uh, what does it,
I guess it's game for. All
right. That's it. That's the
podcast. Go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.